much former vice president joe biden met
with george floyd's family in houston
the family's lawyer said the presumptive
democratic
presidential nominee met with them for
more than an hour yesterday
and quote listened heard their pain and
shared in their woe
in an exclusive interview cbs evening
news anchor norah o'donnell sat down
with biden for a cbs news
special justice for all biden told nora
that he and his wife talked to floyd's
family about how hard it is to grieve
especially with the whole world watching
why do you think george floyd's death is
a wake-up call for this nation
well when people saw
george's face being pushed against with
his nose almost being broken and being
held up for eight minutes and 42 seconds
whatever it was exactly
they said oh my god this is happening
and all the people coming forward but
you know what they told me
they told me how they were encouraged by
the fact that
the protests here in texas and other
places
they were telling me that guess what
mr vice president all the young
white men and women marching with young
black
men and women almost as many it's going
to change
there's hope they have hope
nora will anchor a cbs news special
report from houston today on
george floyd's funeral service and
tonight gail will anchor the primetime
special justice for all
it explores how the activism that we're
seeing now could change racism within
the ranks of law enforcement forever
it will air tonight at 10 9 central
right here on